Olá eu sou uma menina negra eu nasci na
periferia e foi criada por uma mãe
solteira Essa é a mesma realidade de
mais da metade da população brasileira
e eu estudei dos melhores colégios eu
faço faculdade uma das Universidades
mais inovadoras do país aos 16 anos eu
já trabalhava em uma das maiores
multinacionais na área de tecnologia e
hoje eu posso criar projetos que impacta
a vida de outras pessoas que deu certo
na minha receita que não deu na vida de
outros milhões de jovens periféricos e
meninas negras no Brasil
é normalmente a gente cresce ouvindo
aquelas frases dos nossos pais né E no
meu caso eu cresci ouvindo estuda porque
o lápis é bem mais leve do que a
vassoura e seja um grande valor humano
e eu fui criada por uma mãe extremamente
arrojada que me ensinou a ser
protagonista da minha própria vida e me
incentivou a sonhar muito alto e para
Além disso me deu os recursos para que
isso pudesse se tornar realidade de fato
e eu fui ensinado incentivada pela minha
mãe a usar a tecnologia para eu ter
acesso a uma educação de qualidade
porque era isso que é permitir que toda
essa essa projeção pudesse se tornar
realidade e que eu pudesse combater
qualquer tipo de desigualdade que
aparecesse ao longo do meu caminho então
minha mãe me ensinou a tecnologia para
eu estudar para aprender novos idiomas
para mim vou ver para me capacitar e
isso foi essencial no alicerce que foi
solidificado Aparecida desse suporte
desse apoio que recebi a dentro de casa
essa base foi essencial para que eu
pudesse conquistar grandes oportunidades
desde muito nova e conforme eu fui tendo
acesso a essas oportunidades que para
aumentar o meu caminho que me dão
condições para chegar cada vez mais
longe eu comecei a olhar para o lado e
ver que haviam pouquíssimas pessoas que
partilham do mesmo ponto de partida que
o meu caminhando junto comigo
especialmente as meninas negras mas ao
mesmo tempo quando eu li
o outro lado eu vi assim pessoas que
partiram do mesmo lugar que o meu mas
trabalhando em funções como na faxina na
segurança ou na cozinha Teve um dia
durante ensino médio que um amigo meu
virou para mim e perguntou assim Isa
como que é ser pobre eu assisti O
interessante é até engraçado porque às
vezes a gente é de férias não tinha
algum feriado e aí quando a gente
voltava né para escola a gente tava
falando como que foram aqueles dias e o
pessoal ficava falando aí porque eu
viajei para tal e tal lugar eu fiz um
bate-volta em Nova York e eu falava Eu
também viajei eu fui lá para o extremo
sul da zona sul de São Paulo passar os
dias com a minha família lá no Grajaú
assim como eu não tinha a mínima noção
de como que era viver na realidade
dessas pessoas que eu tava convivendo
eles também não tinha a mínima noção de
como que era minha realidade mas essa
pergunta que esse colega me fez foi
muito puro e reveladora por que mostrava
claramente o distanciamento social que
eu vivia todos os dias entre as bolhas
que eu transitava durante
E aí
e de fato Eu sempre me vi como um único
grão de feijão numa imensa panela de
arroz mas viver essa dualidade todos os
dias me causava grandes questionamentos
enquanto de um lado saia de madrugada de
um de uma realidade onde as pessoas são
ditas que não tem perspectiva pela falta
de oportunidades e pela falta de
referências de pessoas falando que sim e
mostrando que é possível algumas horas
depois eu tava no outro planeta onde
tudo de fato era possível e todo mundo
ali tava te dando todos os recursos e
todas as condições para você chegar mais
longe e se a sua melhor versão todos os
dias mas eu me perguntava se enquanto eu
tava tendo acesso a educação de
qualidade faltaram a tecnologia que tava
me preparando para esse futuro incerto
que se aproxima de mim e sabendo que
tantas outras pessoas ao redor não
estavam tendo acesso aquilo
ah e também saber que esse meu colega
que com vivia comigo dali durante o
ensino médio não conhecia a realidade da
maior parte da população do país onde
ele vive antes de me conhecer pela falta
da oportunidade de conviver de aprender
e ambiente diferente do dele eu não
sabia se todos aqueles recursos era de
fato suficiente para que eu e ele por
exemplo pudéssemos causar mudança no
meio desse futuro incerto que estava se
aproximando
e em resposta a esses questionamentos em
2017 e eu e minha mãe fundamos um
iniciativa social chamada a meninas
negras com o objetivo de desenvolver o
plano potencial de jovens da Periferia
para que eles possam ser conectados as
oportunidades e mudar não só sua
realidade mas também serem agente de
transformação em toda a nossa sociedade
a partir disso a gente pode transformar
a vida de vários jovens entre eles a
vida da Giovana que é uma menina negra
portadora de uma deficiência que foi
criada pela sua mãe a dona Edinalva que
a vendedora de Yakult em Itapecerica da
Serra mas quando ela chegou no projeto
ela não tinha perspectiva nenhuma sobre
seu futuro e não conseguia se projetar
para além da realidade Onde Ela vivia
ali dentro da periferia todos os dias e
hoje ela Além de estar no ensino
superior trabalho uma das maiores
empresas de t.i. do mundo construindo
novas tecnologias que já estão
impactando a sociedade ou a vida da
Aline por exemplo que é uma menina
a engenharia da computação inclusive na
mesma Universidade que eu e que também
trabalha em uma multinacional mas uma
das maiores na área de consultoria ou da
Luiza que estuda publicidade e trabalho
uma das maiores agências do mundo até
mesmo da Agnes que hoje também é minha
colega de trabalho na empresa onde eu
trabalho que a hora qo
em todas essas meninas são meninas Claro
negras nascidas na periferia na mesma
faixa etária do que eu e que foram
criadas pelas suas mães e que deu certo
na receita delas assim como na minha foi
a educação EA oportunidade mas quando eu
falo de educação eu queria convidar você
para fazer uma reflexão junto comigo
será que essa educação está sendo de
fato de qualidade enquanto a gente não
tem estudante de todos os contextos
sociais sendo desenvolvidos em conjunto
E essas são as mesmas pessoas que vão tá
liderando o nosso país e as principais
responsáveis por causar mudança na
sociedade daqui alguns anos a chave da
transformação da em oferecer meios para
que todas as pessoas possam ser
desenvolvidas e que elas possam
construir novas tecnologias que vão de
fato impactar na vida de todas as
pessoas e se a democratização do
desenvolvimento tecnológico EA partir
disso que a gente pode reduzir cada vez
mais a sua lacunas sociais que a gente
tem hoje quando a gente pára para pensar
como que vai ser o futuro numa realidade
completamente transformada que que vem
na sua mente que que você pensa quando
alguém fala para você que daqui a alguns
anos o mundo não vai ser da mesma forma
que você conhece hoje
E na verdade a grande questão é como que
a gente quer ter uma sociedade que
prospere se a gente não tá gerando a
inclusão que pode resultar nas inovações
capazes de transformar a nossa sociedade
no meio de um contexto do Global marcado
pela tecnologia
e a pandemia mostrou para todo mundo os
impactos da aceleração digital o que
trouxe aspectos muito positivos mas
outros extremamente preocupantes
e no contexto a gente está vivendo hoje
no meio de uma revolução digital o fórum
econômico mundial já mostra que 65 por
cento dos empregos e das profissões do
futuro ainda não existem e quando a
gente olha para esse dado e a gente sabe
que cinquenta por cento da capacidade
produtiva do Brasil não está sendo
aproveitada e que além desse desperdício
a gente tem uma realidade um de no ano
passado quatro milhões de jovens
abandonaram os estudos a maioria por
questões financeiras Eu não sei você mas
isso me causa uma grande angústia como
que a gente tá preparando as pessoas
para esse contexto que tá chegando
e isso vai causar uma ruptura muito
grande por causa das desigualdades que a
gente tem hoje na nossa sociedade mas ao
mesmo tempo que esse cenário existe a
gente também tem a maior chance da nossa
história de causar uma transformação
sobre o espectro socioeconômico
brasileiro e causar um desenvolvimento
que afeta a vida de todo mundo inclusive
a sua e além de transformar nossa
sociedade também o futuro de todas as
gerações que vão vir depois da gente
e as próximas gerações eu vim cada vez
menor quantidade EA queda da proporção
de jovens na população pode significar a
queda dos níveis de inovação
consequentemente de transformação social
e Clara feita na nossa economia enquanto
a gente não entender que para resolver
os problemas mais críticos da sociedade
a gente precisa enxergar tecnologia como
progresso social EA inovação como uma
mudança social em escala a gente vai
continuar num ciclo vicioso negativo
onde a grande parte das escolas
continuam produzindo analfabetos
funcionais e meia quarta Revolução
Industrial isso faz com que a gente pega
um enorme potencial de transformar e
lapidar o talento que esses jovens
funções contribui ativamente na
transformação social que a gente quer
ter isso enquanto a gente não faz isso a
gente está fazendo com que as
oportunidades de fato se afastem dessas
pessoas gerando um ciclo que leva
diretamente dos bancos escolares para os
emprego
os piores casos nos presídios e até
mesmo no cemitério se a gente for lá
para uma questão social a gente precisa
usar tudo que a tecnologia nos dá
disposição para gente ressignificar a
jornada do ser humano no meio de um
mundo completamente transformado
ó E além disso usar essa esse recurso
para que a gente possa causar para
transformações positivas sobre as
desigualdades sociais que a gente tem
hoje porque isso só atrasa o nosso
atingimento do potencial de
desenvolvimento que a gente pode ter no
Brasil e também no mundo como um todo a
tecnologia ao meio para fazer isso
acontecer mas a mudança efetiva Depende
das pessoas que vai construir essa
ferramenta
E desde que eu me enxergo como parte de
um mundo de pessoas que transformam e
comecei a perceber que o que de fato
gera toda essa mudança é a postura que
cada pessoa assume diante do que ela tem
disse eu me lembro de uma ocasião
durante os trabalhos do meninas negras e
uma das integrantes estava sendo
desenvolvida para ocupar uma posição em
uma das maiores multinacionais de t.i.
na área de tecnologia e enquanto a gente
tava fazendo esse trabalho a mãe dessa
menina chegou para a gente falou Para
gente parar de fazer isso porque ela já
tinha conseguido um emprego de domingo a
domingo onde a filha dela ia ganhar r$
2000 com tudo incluso e a morar no
trabalho que isso garantiria o futuro
dela
é mas a minha mãe conversou com a mãe
dessa integrante do projeto e explicou o
que que esse trabalho traria de
benefício em comparação a uma carreira
que ela poderia construir dentro dessa
grande empresa o que mudaria não sua
vida dessa menina mas de todas as todas
as futuras gerações da sua família e que
bom que a mãe dela entendeu E que apoiou
porque hoje já como estagiária nessa
nessa empresa ela está se desenvolvendo
já teve Inclusive a oportunidade de
fazer sua primeira viagem internacional
como fruto dessa oportunidade E além
disso Ela conseguiu influenciar a
mudança em toda a família dela então a
irmã dela que tava fora da escola voltou
a estudar o irmão que ocupava a cargos
operacionais ou está ensino superior e
também trabalho em uma grande empresa no
ramo
e eu acredito que quanto mais Giovana
salines Luiza Agnes e tantos outros
jovens se desenvolvendo além da gente
mudar a realidade da gente será o único
grão de feijão no imenso a panela de
arroz e a gente poder ter um baião de
dois dentro dessa panela a gente está
construindo a base para que a gente
consiga ter uma sociedade co construída
entre todas as pessoas que podem de fato
gerado inovações em conjunto como fruto
da diversidade que elas trazem
é o Brasil que eu tenho como missão de
qual construir é aquele onde todas as
pessoas consigam entender e valorizar a
potência de transformação que possui e
usar isso para habilitar mudança
e no mundo marcado pela transformação
pela mudança pelas inovações todas as
pessoas têm potência porque todos são
transformadores e todos podem de fato se
agentes ativos no meio desse contexto
Você já parou para pensar o que que você
pode transformar o que você já
transformando se você nunca parou para
pensar nisso eu te faço esse convite
para você fazer essa reflexão
é muito obrigada
E aí